hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
orange comm and today I want to talk to
you about Olli catheters sometimes
during your nursing career or as a
nursing student you will get the chance
to insert a Foley catheter so in this
video I just want to talk about the kit
itself what's included in the kit and
how you prep everything before you
actually insert a Foley catheter on a
patient in the next video I want to make
so be sure to check that out I'm going
to show you how to actually insert a
Foley catheter in a patient and I'll be
using a mannequin and so watch that to
actually see the skill in place so first
you'll want to get your Foley catheter
kit they come like this and they're soft
in your clean mold on your unit be sure
whenever you grab your kit that you get
a kit that contains the holy bag and the
prep supplies because some kids just
have the prep supplies or just the
drainage bag so be sure you read because
there's a piece of paper on the inside
the bag of what it contains so you get
your kit and you open it up this one's
already open but what you do is you just
pill it back and this plaque will come
off I like to use this plastic bag that
comes in as my trash bag because you'll
have things you'll need to throw away
but it's your preference I've learned
over the years it's a lot easier your
kit will come in here you just slide it
out and be very careful and put your bag
aside and around this kit is your
sterile field you have two inches to
grab on the edges so you won't
contaminate your sterile field so what
you do is you carefully just pill it
back and you'll be exposing your kit
which everything inside of here is
sterile so be careful and turn your kit
to the side whenever you're actually
inserting this on a patient it's good to
have your patient in the bed and have
your bedside table on the side and put
your tray next to that and get on the
side where you can use your dominant
hand easily so in the next video like I
said you'll be seeing the actual
do that okay in your kit you have a
bunch of different stuff first thing
right here is a dray this is a sterile
drape that you will use to put over your
patient to protect the sterile field I'm
going to show you what it looks like see
that little opening that can go over the
penis area or the vagina area just to
keep the area nice and sterile and next
are your gloves and after you put your
drape on you want to get your gloves
they have the tray set up pretty much
how everything is stacked is how you are
going to be using it so you'll get your
gloves on take your gloves and lay them
beside of you and you're going to be
putting on these sterile gloves there's
a special technique on how to put on
sterile gloves
I have a video on how to do that so if
you're not wear malecon with sterile
gloves please watch that video so I'm
going to put these on
now have my sterile gloves on and now I
can touch everything that's in this kit
normally because my hands I didn't have
my sterile gloves on I couldn't touch
anything in the kit the only thing
really touch was the drape that you
would drape the patient and so the
reason that they put the drape first and
you don't want to use your sterile
gloves putting on the drape on the
patient is because you increase the
chance of you actually contaminating
your hands so it's okay to do the drape
first without your sterile gloves on
because you'll decrease your chances I'm
contaminating them here's another drape
if you needed it and you can put that
underneath the patient's for them
whatever you want to do it's really your
preference if you want to use that or
not some people like to use the drape
some people don't it's really how you
were taught and the next thing in this
kit you have these tweezers and you have
iodine which is betadine and a lot of
patients are allergic to this again
check allergies it to make sure your
patient isn't allergic to this if they
are you'll have to use a different type
of prep and what you will do with this
is that you will tear this off I'm not
going to tear this off right now but you
would normally tear it off and you have
these three cotton balls right here okay
and you have more right here you
actually have a total of six what you do
is tear it off and you drizzle your
betadine on this and get them saturated
next you have this is just a specimen
cup a lot of doctors will order you to
insert the Foley catheter and then get a
urine specimen so you will use that if
you need that and you also have your 10
cc um sterile water it inflates your
bulb because before you ever insert a
Foley catheter you always check the bulb
to make sure
believe it or not whenever I was fixin
to insert a Foley catheter on a patient
I checked my bowl just like I was
supposed to in the bulb would not in
flight at all
it was a bad Foley so I had to throw it
away and I had to get a new kit and
start all over so that's why you always
check your volleyball because sometimes
they don't work and then this right here
is your lubricant this is what we will
lubricate the Foley catheter up with
because it will be dry and to make it
more comfortable for the patient when
you insert it into the urethra and this
lubricant will help it slide a lot
easier okay so below your kit is the
Foley bag and the Foley catheter itself
right here this is the part that will
actually go into your patient okay um
this brought this port right here is
where you insert the 10 CC sterile water
syringe to inflate this bulb which I'll
show you here in a second what that will
look like to check your hole and then
this port right here is where you would
stick a syringe to suck out your
specimen for your urine so that's what
those two ports are and the urine once
you insert your Foley there's two little
holes right here and once it is hits the
bladder it will start to fill with urine
and it will start to turn yellow right
here with the urine draining and you
know that you're in and the tables like
the urine and gravity will help the
urine flow into the bag and to empty
your Foley catheter this is where you
would empty at you
snap it there and empty it and then
claim to that so that's how that works
so let me show you how to insert or fill
up your bowl so first what you would do
you would get your betta dye ready and
get that and you would want to check
your bulb so you would pop this little
cap off just set it on the side and then
you're going to connect to this it's
easily connects like that make sure it's
on there good and you're going to watch
your bulb
employees do you see it inflating plates
beautifully and then I like to just wait
about 30 seconds look for any leaks make
sure it's all good and it looks great
now after you wait for about 30 seconds
you deflate it and this syringe you
actually just like would go and the
plunger just sucks the water back in and
the deflates like that I like to keep my
syringe connected to that because
whatever I insert the Foley it's just
easier to just inject the sterile water
once you hit the bladder you don't have
to connect and Bumble and have to mess
with everything so that's best okay
right before another tip right before I
actually insert the Foley I keep this in
the plastic thing because whenever
you're messing around with this kit this
thing is going to be flying everywhere
you don't want this to hit outside or
anything like this or anything because
it will contaminate it and you increase
your patient's risk of getting a UTI or
anything so I like to keep it in this
plastic wrap until actually fixing to
insert because it decreases the chances
of contamination
here's your lubricant and like I said
we'll use this to lubricate the area
before or lubricate this the catheter
before we insert it I like to just tear
that off and just squirt it into my tray
and
[ __ ] around and lubricant and then I'm
ready to go so that's everything that's
in your kit one thing that doesn't come
and most holy kids is the little secure
device that you put on the patient's
thigh to keep the Foley in place so
always be sure that you grab that
because that will help decrease the
Foley movie from getting pulled out and
when the patient moves so always do that
so that's how that's what's in your
Foley kit and in my next video I'm going
to show you how to actually insert the
Foley so be sure to check that out if
you have any questions about Foley
catheter kits or your experience share
your experience about it please come to
the website register nurse orange up
home and visit the forum and if you
liked this video please share it with
your friends and thank you so much for
watching